Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the mailbag,
even including a Thanksgiving greetings from some,
I guess unexpected people may be depending on
your perspective from last week. If you want to
have a chance at participating in the mailbag, you
can email info at David Pakman dot com. I do want
to say this again because unfortunately,
we're dealing more and more with this.
If you're emailing every day, we're probably no
longer seeing your messages when people email in
too much. And there are people sending messages
multiple times a day where there's no chance
you're going to be in the mailbag. The emails are
just auto are sort of filtered into a folder and,
you know, let let's quality over quantity. Let's
keep it there. Info at David Pakman dot com. Let's
go right into the first one, which is you're a
loser and a racist and of course, almost mandatory
that your which is supposed to be you
are contracted to y0u apostrophe re
misspelled as y oh, you are my loser and a racist
doesn't make a lot of sense. I don't know when it
became law that when you write hate mail, you
have to put in the wrong your. But certainly we
are seeing that very strongly in our e-mail bag.
So you're a loser and a racist. Thank you, Thomas
wrote in about socialism. This is a good email,
actually, Thomas writes. Your remarks seemed to
indicate that the U.S. doesn't have socialism. If
we take the broad definition, the U.S. has plenty
Social Security, Medicare, minimum wages, cetera
and more than enough government support for large
industries a socialism that predates that for the
majority. One political party has been trying for
decades to eradicate socialism for 70 to 80
percent of the people, which would leave more
wealth to shovel up to the plutocracy. If we don't
take the broad meaning of the word, shouldn't we
also drop the broad meaning of capitalism, vulture
capitalism, vampire capitalism, mom and pop
operations, etc. corporations and the financial
behemoths that use wealth of the capital class
to rake more of it up for them? A lot of really
good points here and points that we've made. When
when I say the United States is not a socialist
country, what I mean is that at the top level,
socialism, including a socialized ownership
of the means of production, is not the model.
Thomas is completely correct that in certain
areas we do have socialized services and you
can even include more police. In most places. Some
places have sort of like private police forces,
but police in most places. Firefighters in most
places. Social Security is a socialization of
sorts. Medicare, yes, we we have the military.
And so when we say we are not a socialist country,
we mean one thing about it. We mean when the
right says it's socialist to. Have Obama phones,
as Jesse Lee Peterson once told me or whatever.
This is not a socialist country or government
at the top level, but we have socialist elements
within it, for sure. Next e-mail is from Bruce.
Bruce says, David, what I'm wondering is when is
it Elon Musk going to hop on one of these B arcs
that he is creating and going to crash into Venus,
which is the planet he wants the Earth to become?
Yeah, there's a lot more A. Elon Musk sentiment in
the email lately. And I did. If you're interested
in the topic of Elon Musk and Tesla from
the electric vehicle standpoint on Friday,
on Black Friday, I did a stream where we did a
lot of different things. But one of the things
is I did talk about my increased Oh, it's not
dissatisfaction, but less enthusiasm about Tesla
as the future of electric vehicles. I think Tesla
was an early mover, and when it comes to the range
of their vehicles, they're second to none. But
there are other companies, including General
Motors, Audi, just about all of them that are,
generally speaking, better at building vehicles.
And I talked about where I believe Tesla is
going to start having problems. It's less
about the personality cult around Elon Musk. But
if you're interested in that topic, check out
that live stream from Black Friday. Very, very
powerful livestream. OK. Here is a Thanksgiving
greeting maybe you guys did not expect on Thursday
Thanksgiving. I got to email an email from Jimmy
from Philly that furious, angry Trumpist who calls
in and he said simply, Happy Thanksgiving. There
was no attack. There was no insult. There was no
slur or the homophobia or transphobia that we've
come to expect from Jimmy from fairly simply.
Happy Thanksgiving. He does email me sometimes
just just to say hello. So not sure how many of
you were surprised by that, but I did receive
that. Next question is from Jeff Jeff Wright in
writing Is this why the big microphone David, sir?
I see people online using tiny larval ear mikes
and they sound fine or those that wrap around your
face. I know this is a stupid question, but why
do you use such a Big Mike? At least it doesn't
obscure your mouth like other YouTubers. I hope
you're not compensating for anything big fan and
website member yet. You know, I've talked about
this before. There's a couple of different reasons
that I've stuck with the Big Mike. When we years
ago when we tried the clip on lovelier mikes.
We didn't have the ones that sounded that good. So
I'm completely open to switching to a live mike,
if someone can recommend to me one that
really will sound as good as one of these
larger condenser microphones. But a lot of people
just listen to this show via the audio podcast.
I don't want to have damaged sound quality. That's
one reason. The second reason is our main studio
is very well treated from the standpoint of Echo
and deadening the room and all of that stuff.
Our backup studio, which we now have, is not,
and using a livelier mic when I've tested it
is insanely echoey. And when traveling, I've
got some travel upcoming where I'm going to
be doing the show from different locations.
It's so unpredictable what the room treatment
is going to be. You might be, you know, a could
be a hotel room with those kind of like padded.
Almost like it's just it's like a painting, but
it's just padded fabric, you know, it's kind of
like it now, which helps the dead in the sound
and carpets and whatever. Or it can be really
echoey because it's so unpredictable. The large
canister microphone just seems to sound better,
but if someone can recommend a good love,
that really will will perform well in all of
these scenarios. I will switch to it. Trust
me when I travel and I bring the big boy,
I think every time it would be great to
have a tiny little microphone. All right,
Jeff. So I hope that's a comprehensive enough
answer. This is a very sad email from Matthew.
Matthew says conspiracy theory ont or he's
from New York, so I guess he would say,
aren't I Matthew from New York? My whole family is
diverse. Republican members Trumpists Trump haters
don't like the rhetoric but will vote for policies
and just classic Republican members. But all,
as I know, vaccinated except one my aunt. She
has conspiracy theories about the vaccine and
the left so much that she thinks Trump is saying
get the vaccine as a reverse psychology technique.
I don't know what to do. I don't want to cut off,
but I'm feeling I feel like I'm enabling her every
time I talk to her about politics. What do I do?
You know, I get these questions all the time. I
can't tell you, Matthew, what to do. You have
to decide what is the emotional, psychological,
mental health impact of being in contact with
someone who is so disconnected from reality?
Versus how much do you value the relationship with
her and what effect it would have to cut her off
in terms of the relationships between you and
other people in the family? I can't answer that
question for you. What I think is very interesting
about this particular conspiracy theory is that
it's an example of an end you. It's indivisible,
it's un falsifiable, right? Because if Trump
were to say, don't get the vaccines, a lot of
these folks would say, See, Trump is saying,
don't get it. And if Trump says, get it, anyone
like Matthews art can say it's reverse psychology.
What he really is wanting people to do is not to
get it, even though he's saying that you should
get it. So that's any kind of un falsifiable claim
like that is very, very tough because no matter
what he says, they come to the same conclusion. So
I don't really have advice on the personal thing,
but it is a very tough conspiracy theory to
deal with. Next message came in via Facebook.
I don't suppose you would be interested
to hear or see this, but the restaurants
in my town have started to put. Let's go
Brandon on the bottom of tickets. I figured,
you know what it means. Guymon Oklahoma pub on
the bricks. Yeah, I've seen reports of this where
you go, you know, oftentimes at restaurants. The
receipt has some kind of message at the bottom.
Sometimes it's thank you for your business. Happy
holidays. Thank you for coming. We appreciate you
stuff like that. There are some restaurants that
have started to put at the very bottom of the rest
of the restaurant receipt. Let's go, Brandon,
which is, of course, code for Joe Biden. It's
one of the cringe, yes, new right wing phrases
which they think is super clever. And it's not.
I wouldn't go to such a restaurant if I ever saw
that at the bottom of of a receipt, I would never
go back. Everybody's got to decide for themselves
what to do. Last one coming in via Twitter.
This user says, David Pakman, you seem to
suffer from a pretty severe case of autism
that has only intensified over the years.
It's hilarious that you'd call anyone a doofus
referring to the judge in the Rittenhouse case.
It's hilarious that you'd call anyone a doofus.
How hard were you bullied growing up, or were you
just socially awkward to the point of becoming
socially crippled? Very, very big shot
across the bow. Of course, if anybody knew
about my first jobs, which I've talked about here
on the show, which were very, very much sales
oriented, dependent on rapidly reading social cues
and building rapport with people you've just met,
you might come away with a different
conclusion, but a very interesting response here
to me saying that Rittenhouse judge was wacky,
wasn't he? So congratulations to everybody who
got their messages into the mailbag today. You
can write in info at David Pakman dot com. You
might notice all of the emails that get on
our one paragraph, so the multi-page emails
as much time as may have gone into them,
which we appreciate very much. They're not
going to make it onto the mailbag, and we have
a fantastic bonus show coming up for you today.
Sign up at join Packman dot com. You will get
access to the bonus show instantly, as well as the
commercial free audio and video feeds of the show.
Speaker 3: We will see you then.